Hello? Of Amy.
Who? I don't know what's going on.
I do. Handmaids out.
They
really listen to you.
You figured out I have the belt in my safe.
You thought you could distract me and steal
the key.
I did think those things, Yes.
And then I did it.
Please. Impossible.
The key has been in my shoe the entire time.
Okay, well, it's almost midnight.
Why don't you try and use your key?
It fits.
I knew you were lying. You are so
predictable. Uh-Oh, it's not turning.
I guess I'm not quite as predictable as you
thought. And I also bet none of you can
predict what I'm going to do next.
Use your key to open the safe and act like a
dick about it. Yes, obviously.
That's what I'm going to do. Rosa. Just have
to be so spot on all the time.
If I may just get my skirt up.
Thanks. Oh, look at that.
The key fits and the lock is turning and the
safe is empty.
What? There's no cummerbund.
Never was. It was always a belt.
I don't.
Understand who took.
It. We haven't heard from Charles in an hour.
Maybe he betrayed the tramps.
Oh, God. I just called us the tramps.
What have I become?
It's not Charles. I locked him.
Up. I put a GPS tracker on the belt.
It's on the move and it's going fast.
Let's take my bike. They'll never catch us
later, dorks.
Should we follow them? Hey, Captain, why are
you giggling?
I put a GPS tracker inside of Terry.
Sarge, Kevin purchased one too many full fat
French yogurts.
You want it? Absolutely.
Enjoy. Enjoy.
Devious. I know.
But I also put a tracker in Terry's yogurt.
Same here. No reason.
Just because you're a great sergeant.
Now suck it down.
Yeah, no problem.
Take it. Swallow the gurt.
Do you guys think all that radiation is bad
for him?
I'm sure it'll be fine.
He's lived a long life already.
Yeah. Good luck keeping up with me.
I've done my morning calisthenics, oh I'll
keep up with you.
Rwaa. In hell
. Hello, Jacob. Ames, what are you doing
here? Why aren't you out looking for the
belt? You and
I both know the belt never left the
precinct. I don't know that.
Nobody knows
that. I kept thinking, how did anyone swap my
key? And then it hit me.
They didn't. They swapped the safe.
One of the handmaids, I'm assuming fake.
Charles took my safe and then of Amy
deposited a lookalike.
What did you give fake Charles? So he'd help
you?
Nothing. In fact, he gave me something.
The power of financial freedom.
I invested in a pyramid scheme.
It's no time to go into it right now.
Okay, so while we all try to figure out who
had the real key, fake Charles broke into
the safe, removed the tracker and let Terry
and the whole squad on a wild goose chase.
My only question is, which box is the belt
in?
Well, good luck figuring it out because the
clock is tick. Tick.
Tocking. It's that one.
No, the dust pattern on top doesn't match its
neighbors. You see, Jake, I'm always going
to be one step ahead of you.
You've lost the ability to surprise me.
You just plain boring.
Again, weird take on our very loving
relationship.
And it's midnight, so I guess I'm an amazing
human slash genius.
Yeah. Although.
You might want to read the inscription on
that they're belt.
Why? Oh, no.
What does it say?
Amy Santiago, will you marry me?
Surprise.
I was so confused.
I don't know what's happening right now.
I'm so confused. I don't know what's
happening right now. Title of your sex tape.
Oh, my God. I'm shaking.
I'm definitely going to cry.
Title of your sex tape.
Wait, is this really happening?
Is this part of the heist?
If this is part of the heist, I will dump
you so hard.
No, please. It's like it's really happening,
okay? It's not part of the heist.
I promise. This is real.
It is?
Yeah. Okay, here it goes.
Ames, I love you.
I love how smart you are.
I love how beautiful you are.
I love your face.
And I love your butt.
I should have written this down first.
No, no, it's okay.
Go on.
I love how much you pretend to, like, die
hard.
I like the second one.
You don't have to. Okay?
Yeah. You're kind and you're funny, and
you're the best person I know.
And the best detective.
Also, for reals. I love your butt.
I love yours, too.
Gross.
Amy Santiago.
Will you marry me?
Jake Peralta. I will marry you.
I love you so much.
Hey, Cherkos. This little tramp escaped.
So that ought to teach.
Did you just.
And did you say.